my first impression of Anthony was a
very positive one he was a great soccer
player he remind me the body and the
movements and the dribble remind me a
lot of name mark he have a lot of skills
in the key squad la he was ice core
leader if you compare like a basketball
like you see liberal very quite outside
but on a few was like a giant
[Music]
he's a leader here the kind of person
that people follow that was a
professional club in Brazil and they was
very impressed with the games that we
require here and one of the players was
Anthony they say if they could invite
them to come to Brazil and do a tryout
there was a possibility
I believe that Anton was on the right
direction with the right connection he
could play professional football I like
to play soccer every day I try hard to
do my best
[Music]
I've just gotten a horrific piece of
news Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
School and active shooting situation
parkland is a quiet community it's a
community that's known for its parks
it's a place where people move to
specifically because of the schools and
because it's known to be a good place to
raise a family
we came here 12 years ago we like the
people the city we was looking for a
better education for our songs
Anthony joined the FCPS call out to one
of our child the opportunity for a local
talent to participate it's beyond a
dream come true to them if they're able
to watch their heroes on TV and be able
to play for the same Academy learn the
same drills they are leaving their
dreams we decided to move near to the
club and the way he can enjoy and
participate in the club initially when
we got the call we were told that there
was a shooting on the campus shots have
been fired
and several people are being treated by
emergency personnel the uber driver
dropped Cruz off here in front of the
school
he walked on to the campus got into the
freshman building Anthony got a glimpse
of Nicholas Cruz coming up the stairwell
when I released the protein gives cause
I hear the conchos
he tried to run into one of the
classrooms he was unable to make it but
he was able to help make sure that the
door to the classroom he was trying to
get into closed so that the students
inside that classroom were protected
Anthony was shot a number of times
walk me through what happened policy you
can do it in Spanish if you want I fell
in the yo Pensacola marina he said a la
puerta y Luisa porque como yo marina
kisses I mean Ultima momento a la una
Casa Loma de la via I come out I turn
like I was gonna die and say thank you
for everything he said that I get up
shot in my leg and and in my back - and
it was the real the real day yeah
Anthony was left in the hallway of the
freshman building
[Music]
[Applause]
first responders found him about 40
minutes after the shooting he took his
shirt off and tied up his legs so he
stopped the blood and I think that
saving his life Cruz shot and killed
several students on the third floor
injured several others this is believed
to be the deadliest high school shooting
in America
talking about soccer where his goals was
he lost your fraternity do is take away
from him because he was hurt rent vet
his body sustained five bullet wounds in
his legs back and armpit he's got a
metal rod in the bone of his left thigh
a metal piece in his right leg he's
undergone 11 surgeries and still cannot
move the toes on his left foot
they remove part of the liver there in
part of the alarm it was hard because I
can't like take a shower brush my teeth
go to the fetcher thank God
alice is here alias isa like I received
a text from Barcelona clue when we
watched the news the club he said that
this guy is inspiring us we want to help
and support the family and anthem
he made that invitation they had to wait
for him to be healthier in order to
experience a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity we tried to tell him you
know what Anthony they call you from
Barcelona they they try to reach you
he was so sleepy because he going to a
sturdy they say like they ask you he
went to surgery so happy today I was
like what this is now a real maybe I
mostly think my dreams is always to be a
professional can go play with Barcelona
I personalize my life is my dream I was
two months in the hospital
[Music]
that feeling that I wanna see my team
improve him to recover it faster it was
a miracle he said you know what mom I
need to move forward I want to touch
that grass
Anthony Bohr has has won the hearts of
folks here in parkland the nation and
really a hospital and being hailed a
hero
Anthony Borges who suffered five gunshot
wounds as he helped bring 20 students to
safety 2019 young hero honoree Anthony
Borges
is we're like people coming here I'd
ever have to lose I don't think I want a
car like here I think the definition for
him is different hero doesn't get hurt
that's why I said what are you coming
hero if you get tri bullying I can play
football again it it was so hard because
theorem only has to handle the situation
about your body you have to thinking
about mentally what you went through
it's a small body that has so much pain
and so much damage he sometimes he got
nightmares he wake up in the middle of
the night crying sweaty and kind of
scared he'd say I'm going to Barcelona
it's gonna be the biggest thing he's
gonna trace the whole bad thing happened
to him
[Music]
amazing I'll have what I really want to
play now I wanna go there showing him
what we are doing here what he did in
the porcelain Academy in followed is
exactly the same well it's me a lot to
me is like a miracle it's a dream come
true after all the tragedy he can play
again super emotional because we never
think anything able even work how he can
run
[Music]
so the scene is set
see
[Applause]
this is big men's football boss
everybody once again
[Applause]
Anthony's a great kid I think God has
some missions for him I gotta believe
that I want to believe that because with
all the warm is aldershot enter was not
supposed to be alive
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]